what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
couple videos i saw in tik tok they're
kind of
they're a little random like the topics
don't really go together but
i don't know i just thought you guys
would find them interesting and
entertaining i know my manosphere
content when i see it before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay add to this young lady okay i need
to like refresh this so it goes to the
front hold on
the question what do you bring to the
table it's a tactic to be little woman
and i also want to add to this young
lady's video because i think she made an
amazing point
but different men value different things
than women there are men out there who
do value beauty and beauty only
you that's true that's true i've seen
girls that are absolute wenches
get a pretty good husband just because
they're hot okay i've seen that
guys will say that women do this all day
but guys do the same thing these
stunning women who are probably not the
brightest
and they are in really great
relationships in marriages i have seen
men right but that's because they're
agreeable which is one thing
but i've seen girls that are absolute
[ __ ]
build the confidence of women with no
self-worth i've seen average looking
women in happy relationships
women who are insecure or overweight in
happy relationships
all in all and i tell you this all the
time please stop listening to men who
are telling you what is valuable in
women
because okay that's where i disagree um
i was in sales and i think it's really
important to talk to the customer about
what they look for
so you should only listen to women that
that doesn't make sense
women are born with value we are that's
true
that's true women are born with value
ones who have the power of choice
that's true women i would say most women
have more options than
like men in general we have better
quality suitors than men
did she just admit that women are low
quality
do not let them interrogate you and ask
you these belittling questions
because as a woman it doesn't matter who
you are what you do or what disability
you have
you will always add value to a man's
life false
i've seen girls destroy men's lives like
that is false the question what do you
bring to the table
okay and this sort of
entitlement to having a partner and
having a relationship
is the reason that manosphere really
started in my opinion like
going to say any woman is going to bring
value into a man's life
there are some girls that literally are
so
toxic on the red pill archive to see if
he's in the side
second thing i'm gonna i'm about to
refresh this do you want to find out a
man's reddit user
they're coming for you okay guys they're
coming for you name so you can search on
the red pill archive to see if he's a
misogynistic piece of [ __ ]
cool me too i got you finding someone's
reddit username
might be considered unethical i also
think that hating women with a deep
fiery passion is unethical so
this came up on my for you page i'm not
even on reddit are you guys on reddit
you do you here's a little disclaimer
pause to read
people reuse usernames all the time
online
because of this his reddit username
might be hiding in plain sight on
other platforms first place to look
snapchat put that username straight into
reddit see what happens
venmote usernames super random but
sometimes it works
gamertags if you know a man's gamer tag
this is so much work
oh my god why don't you just ask him if
he knows who kevin samuels is
boom i saved you so much work you
probably know the reddit username they
reuse these all the time i don't know
why
smart guys won't use this but i know a
lot of dumb guys
and they will just literally use their
email address
minus the gmail.com spotify
just trust me on this one i'm gonna do a
part two because there's so many more do
you want
they're coming for you oh if you're
watching this i need you to not watch
this and i really need you to
i need to refresh sorry sometimes they
start playing
here's the situation mom if you're
watching this i need you to not watch
this and i really need you to not watch
this
and i really need you to thank you mom
so
the guy i wanted to have a one night
stand while i was on the bachelorette at
the bachelorette party
and since send
here's the situation mom if you're
watching this i need you to not watch
this and i really need you to not watch
this and i really need you to thank you
mom
so if you have to say that i wouldn't
put it on the internet
just my two cents the guy i wanted to
have a one night stand while i was on
the bachelorette at the bachelorette
party
and it didn't it wasn't a one-night
stand it was also the next day and then
texting me the last day
and then texting me still and i'm so
like mad at myself about it because i'm
actually sad and i
actually miss him and before this i had
no romantic prospects at all and i was
just
living the best life and i was so happy
and and this
is why i say i don't think women are
meant to have casual one-night stance
and casual hookups
like she seems like a sweet girl i
follow her she seems super nice
and now she's in the situation where she
misses a guy that she really barely
knows
and now i have this like oh like this
sadness on my heart and i
hate it like i will never ever ever ever
do a one-night stand ever again because
i'm not that kind of person i get too
attached
does anyone relate to that like i'm so
but i really thought i could be that
girl that just like
had one night santa didn't care but like
it's not me like i like genuinely care
about this person who lives
thousands of miles away who i'm probably
never gonna see again
and here's here's the thing i i have a
theory
and it's tough because there are girls
that will 100
like i have a i have a friend that would
tell me she's so glad
she did all the one night stands that
she did whatever before she met like her
current um her current husband
and but i have a theory i don't think
women are meant to do that
i don't i think the majority of women
don't want to admit like that they
shouldn't have like
done the casual hookups that they did
like there's 27
000 women that liked this
here's the situation sorry and obviously
like they're not gonna comment because
people people can see comments then like
you're admitting to something but
i don't know every girl
that i know that has said that oh i
don't regret it
if you really talk to them and really
get it out of them they'll admit
that at some point they're really like
emotionally hurt by something
that happened through one of those
casual relationships so
i i don't know not
not my thing i don't think it's good for
women but yeah these are just the three
videos i wanted to show you guys
i'd like save random videos that i see
on tick tock to show you guys
um so let me know if you like these type
of videos in the comments don't forget
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time